hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse Orion comm and we're going to talk
about rolling veins have you ever heard
the term that someone used whenever they
missed an IV and they said oh the vein
rolled or someone asked you to the vein
roll and you're like what are they
talking about
well I remember wondering what in the
world was a rolling vein whenever I was
a nursing student and after I became a
nurse no one really told me what it was
I figured it out for myself because I
think a lot of people don't know what
the term rolling veins means what it
means whenever a vein rolls is whenever
you go to insert into the skin into the
vein you see it the vein just moves to
the side and here in a second I'm going
to show you what it looks like when a
vein rolls and I'm going to show you how
to tell if you have a rolling bank
because some veins are a little bit more
susceptible to rolling than other veins
and what you can do to stabilize a vein
so it doesn't roll on you because you
can prevent this from happening so
things that cause a vein to roll one
thing is excessive skin if you have a
patient who's had a lot of weight loss
or they're elderly they have a lot of
saggy skin that can cause a vein to roll
because you see the vein it's nice its
plump you put on your tourniquet but if
you have excess skin hanging down you
it's going to cause once you go in that
skin to move that vein and that's going
to roll away from you
another thing is that some veins that
are found in the hand on your forearm or
your antecubital antecubital area which
is the AC area like to roll if you're
not stabilizing the vein keeping the
patient making a fist or keeping the arm
straight it will roll and patients who
move whenever you poke them with the
needle because getting poked with a
needle hurts so whenever you go to poke
them with the needle and they move it
can cause the vein to move and another
reason is not stabilizing the vein even
though if the vein doesn't look like
it's going to roll or it does it's not a
rolling vein it's always a great idea
that you stabilize the vein and I'll
show you how to do that so first let's
talk about and let me show you how to
tell if a
we'll roll here I wanted to demonstrate
for you what it looks like and how to
tell if a vein will roll the best way to
assess if the vein that you're going to
use is going to roll is to touch it and
to see so right here if I was going to
draw blood or start an IV on this
patient I would use this feign it is
beautiful it's big it's engorged it's
great but let's see if it rolls so what
you do is just take your index finger
and just gently move it and watch I do
that see how that rolls to the side that
if when you go in with a needle what's
going to happen if you're not
stabilizing this vein it's just going to
go to the side and that's what it means
rolling vein another analogy I like to
think of with a rolling vein think of if
you're a fisherman and you're going out
fishing and you have your worm and
you're needing to put that worm on the
hook and the worms wiggling and you're
trying to hook it and if you don't
stabilize that worm you're not going to
be able to hook it and it's the same
concept when trying to get edged needle
into a vein if you're not stabilizing
this it's just going to roll to the side
so let me show you some ways on how to
stabilize the vein first one thing you
can do is you can hold above the
insertion point where you're going to go
in at so say you're going to go in right
here what you need to do is just hold
above the insertion point and sort of
press down a little bit and then just
pull that and see that keeps that vein
nice and stable and it's really not
moving so whenever we go in with our
needle it's going to stay straight
another thing you can do is you can hold
the skin taut but watch out for that
because see if I hold it too tight
notice how that vein disappears and it
goes flat not good so you want to you
can hold it time holding it tight is
best for people who have that excess
skin that we are talking about at the
beginning you could just take it just
pull it back if you need help
always get someone to help you many
times I've had people help me when doing
this and the best thing to do another
way you can stabilize a vein is have the
patient make a fist
so make a fist for me and just the
contraction of the fist and holding that
down will hold the vein
steady so you don't have to hold it on
so anytime you're starting and
Ivy in the hand and the vein is going to
roll have the person make a fist because
that will keep the vein nice and
straight now let me show you a little
bit with an AC vein okay I quickly
wanted to cover the antecubital veins
because a lot of times these veins are
so good to draw and start IVs on because
they're naturally big but a lot of times
new beginners they have problems with
these veins rolling and one tip I want
to give you to prevent missing a vein in
the AC it's always have your patient
bend their elbow out just like that have
them straighten that out because it'll
keep these veins nice and straight if
it's bent like that whenever you go in
the vein might roll so just a quick tip
have them extend that arm out and it'll
stabilize the vein and again you can
hold up the insertion point or hold the
skin tone but that I want to share that
with you real fast okay so that is how
you stabilize a vein that rolls and
water rolling vein is I hope this video
helped helped you out be sure to check
out my other videos on hand veins how to
start an IV and things like that four
tips for drawing blood or starting IVs
and thank you so much for watching and
please subscribe to this youtube channel